i am indeed yesterday with irena crush
irena first of all big congratulations
you're taking a huge step forward to the
grand finals uh how did that
game play out in your head before
it started
um yeah so i would say that this game
was um
it couldn't have gone any better right
from the way like i mean i basically
carried out the strategy that i set
before the game and um
and what was that strategy yeah what was
that strategy i mean should i tell you
my strategy for the match maybe after
the match kershaw
but i think if you just look at this
game you will understand what the
strategy was and um and i'm just happy
that i that i executed it one thing that
you mentioned yesterday when we were
questioning you about this match was
that alice lee plays very fast
nevertheless she was almost at any point
ahead of you on time was that part of
the strategy without revealing too much
yeah yeah yeah that's a good uh question
right i mean because that was a very
very noticeable thing about her games in
this tournament is that she was having
her opponents um at a big time
disadvantage so of course i didn't want
to have a repeat of that and yeah this
game i always had at least a little bit
more time and i actually managed to
build up more valid as we got to the end
um and that i think is very important
yes because i mean clearly she was not
so comfortable having like a kind of a
difficult position and less time on the
clock it wasn't a situation that she'd
been in yet in this tournament so i
think that cl the time management was a
big big factor in this game when do you
feel like you're taking over the
initiative in this game um yeah this
game was very interesting right because
it's a lot of sort of like at a distance
play right not a lot of forcing stuff
going on in the beginning at this point
i mean i thought things were still kind
of unclear but i'll tell you the moments
where i felt things were going well for
me it was a little a couple of moves
later
um yeah right here by the way i just
wanted to show you i don't know if you
guys mentioned this point after a4
bishop a6 you know i was somewhat
tempted by the move rook c6
i just the idea like okay if she attacks
my rook i can go back to c2 and then
play rook d1 and sort of gain like a
little bit of a tempo or rook c1 maybe
right but then i realized after rook c6
i actually have to calculate all these
knight moves to c5 now i don't know like
i felt like probably should be good for
me but like after bishop b7 and queen d7
um you know i just wasn't that
interested in this line so i was like no
this is exactly the kind of stuff you
don't need to do irina you know
make it complicated
and so i went rook d won and still i
wasn't so sure about you know the
evaluation rook d1 c6 rook c1 and right
here was i think one of the difficult
moments i mean when i decided to play
knight d3
um because of course it lets her trade
off the bishop which is not amazing but
on the other hand it was hard for me to
improve my night otherwise and
at the point when i realized that my
other knight could come back to this
square you know um that was when i knew
i was i think had things under control
right here like i was very happy after
91
and then white just has a pretty clear
advantage and just
like it's all one way
exactly it seemed to me irina that
really uh
because of the rest of the game you kept
control strategically wonderful you kind
of probed some weaknesses and eventually
won the material and won the game it was
almost like
the
spirit of the position
was defined
right here at this moment when alice
played rook c8 and followed up with c6
it would have been a completely
different type of middle game had she
played the move c5 a much more active
move i mean of course you can go to some
kinds of
different you know hanging pawn
structures or isolated queen pond
structures and i'm sure you you know uh
you you have a a
an edge but it was sort of like alice
really didn't have a clear plan after
she got into
the strategic waters that you wanted
keep the pieces on the board keep it
static that's a very good point yeah so
right of course c5 was a major idea for
black in this game it was always the
question right was she going to play c5
or not exactly it's a huge question
right and actually you want your
opponents thinking about things like
that having difficult decisions like
that like where they you know they have
a move that takes the game in a
completely different direction and it's
not forced she doesn't have to play c5
right it's like you cannot it's not like
c6 immediately you look at the
positioner like oh it's terrible for
black no it doesn't look like that right
doesn't you don't see the danger and so
but yeah i mean uh c5 was a definitely
more more active move
it's it's all gone so swimmingly well
what
what have you been doing uh during this
pandemic where you're suddenly i mean
you're not playing playoffs you're
you're doing great
uh
you're scoring well and you you you
you've now won the first game of the
match
yeah what's your secret my secret oh i
have a couple of secrets you know
let's one of them is i go for walks
every day so i've been doing that the
whole tournament
um i've also been going to church the
last three days you know because uh
today is actually thank you yes today is
uh easter according to the orthodox
calendar so it's quite a quite a you
know it's a very big holiday you know
and i think on these days i'm always
kind of inspired to play well and on the
days when i've been having to play on
easter which is never my preference
right because i'm always like begging
please don't schedule the tournaments on
these dates you know but if it does
happen and i have to play and even
though it's you know it's quite
difficult but um
but somehow i've managed to do well on
these days
all right well keep it up you still have
a very very big game tomorrow well done
arita thank you guys